so this is really interesting Donald
Trump tweeted about the Confederate flag
in the context of NASCAR and it became a
really big topic at yesterday's press
briefing with Donald Trump's press
secretary Kaley mcenany so just to
refresh refresh you a little bit on
these press briefings they start very
late they are very very short few
questions are taken and they almost
always end with a scripted walk off line
from Caylee Mackin Annie they want these
to be sort of like Mike drop moments the
trumpets love them I cringe when I see
them and yesterday the topic of Donald
Trump's tweet about the Confederate flag
was a big topic of conversation just to
refresh the tweet once again Trump
tweeting yesterday has Bubba Wallace
apologized to all of those great NASCAR
drivers and officials who came to his
aid stood by his side and were willing
to sacrifice everything for him only to
find out that the whole thing was just
another hoax that and flag decision has
caused the lowest ratings ever so as a
result of the tweet a bunch of questions
yesterday about it does Trump want the
Confederate flag in more places
is Trump supporting the Confederate flag
and Caylee Mac and Annie kept repeating
Trump isn't making a judgment one way or
the other about the flag which of course
is exactly the problem we want to hear
Trump's opinion on the flag here's one
question asked yesterday done Killy to
follow up on Peters question what is the
president's position does he think
NASCAR made a mistake by banning the
Confederate flag so he said he I spoke
to him this morning about this and he
said he was not making a judgment one
way or the other
the intent of the tweet was to stand up
for the men and women of NASCAR and the
fans and those who have gone and this
rush to judgment of the media to call
something a hate crime when in fact the
FBI report concluded this was not an
intentional racist act and it very much
mirrors other times when there have been
a rush to judgment let's say with the
Covington boys or with Jesse Smollett so
she won't answer
she says Trump told me you know Caylee
I'm not making a judgment one way or the
other obviously that didn't happen they
are making a calculated optics decision
not to say one way or the other if you
ask me of course I just say yeah I'm
against the Confederate flag
being displayed Jonathan Karl from ABC
News tries a second time to get an
answer about the flag because Cayley
continues to try to obfuscate and talk
about other things didn't go much better
let's drill down on the confederate flag
does he think it was a mistake for
NASCAR to ban it the president said he
wasn't making a judgment one way or the
other you're focusing on one word at the
very bottom of a tweet that's completely
taken out of context and neglecting the
complete rush to judgment our ratings
are down because they banned the flag
that's what he said and the president
was noting the fact that in aggregate
this notion that NASCAR men and women
who have gone and who are being demeaned
and called racist and being accused in
some venues of committing a hate crime
against an individual those allegations
were just dead wrong so again she won't
answer and she insists Trump is not
judging the Confederate flag one way or
the other well that's the problem Caylee
what we're trying to do is figure out
what is Trump's position on the
Confederate flag is Trump actually so
desperate for the racist vote that he's
afraid to denounce the Confederate flag
or play coy at least with it the answer
appears to be yes now just for reference
this is really interesting for two
reasons
I found a video of Trump five years ago
talking about the Confederate flag
Confederate monuments the video is
fascinating for two reasons number one
Trump very clearly says it should be
taken down and put in a museum he just
says it very clearly unequivocally the
other thing that's interesting is Trump
sounds far more articulate and coherent
take a look at the video you're the lone
Republican presidential candidate who
has yet to weigh in on whether or not
you think the Confederate flag should be
flying above the Statehouse in South
Carolina do you think it needs to go I
think it probably does and I think they
should put it in the museum let it go
respect whatever it is that you have to
respect because it was a point in time
and put it in a museum but I would take
it down yes so that is not a Donald
Trump who still exists number one that
Donald Trump doesn't exist and that
Trump is no longer willing to say it
should just be put away in a museum it's
not it doesn't have a place out in
public the Confederate flag Trump is
also not nearly as lucid and coherent as
he was five years ago so
Kaleigh maca nanny now can't say this
they realize i guess that they need the
racist confederate vote but more
importantly i want to mention this
culture war component here here's for me
the really important takeaway from this
the right loves to accuse the left of
fighting a culture war its trump who has
lost on every substantive policy issue
and now has been relegated to making the
issues of the last two weeks statues and
monuments confederate ones confederate
flags sports team names nascar and
claiming that he's fighting radical
anarchist Marxists who of course don't
exist
that's the hill apparently they're
choosing just do to not necessarily die
on but to plant a flag on to keep to use
the metaphor and that is the culture war
right i mean we on the left are talking
about coronavirus science medical policy
public health the economy tax plans the
failures of our health care system
foreign policy they are the ones making
it about this now i know you can say
well but there are people on the Left
who are trying to take down the
monuments okay
that is not the big issue on the left it
has been almost exclusively the issue of
trump for the last ten days maybe this
is an oversimplification but intangible
issues are easier to claim victory on
you can't claim that you replaced
obamacare like you promised because you
didn't you can't claim victory on the
virus even though they've sort of been
trying to because people see the numbers
with stuff like defending our monuments
and our culture i guess you can try to
claim victory i don't know if it'll work
one of our sponsors today is hydrant and
they are giving my audience 25 percent
off your first order this has been a
game changer for me this is a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into your water to rehydrate your body
because it is packed with the four
essential electrolytes that your body
needs the most that's sodium potassium
magnesium and zinc and because of how
hydrant is formulated it's an efficient
way of getting yourself rehydrated and
it tastes awesome there's a variety of
flavors i
blood-orange which I love you can also
get grapefruit and lime a lot of us
don't even realize when we're dehydrated
a lot of the time and it's become a
really great part of my daily routine if
I'm under hydrated I'm affected
physically I'm affected mentally and I
think you never fully understand this
until you use hydrant for the first time
I get a great boost of energy when I'm
properly hydrated if I've been
dehydrated they also have a version with
caffeine which I love if and when that's
what I'm looking for everyone in my
audience gets 25 percent off your first
order when you go to drink hydrant calm
/ Pakman or just enter the code Pakman
at checkout I've put the link right
underneath this video